what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to geek culture explain and
in this video we are talking about the
thunderbolts yes i am so excited to talk
about the thunderbolts been looking
forward to it all week the roster the
film the whole nine yards it all has me
so excited
tim what are you doing here man i got a
video to record
plus i gotta do the integration for
super
oh yeah i forgot we had that integration
okay well you're doing that will you
give me a cup of coffee
nope
all right you know what let's let's
move this chair out of the way and move
this chair out of the way you know what
we're gonna go ahead and close this
thing what's going on y'all
it's tim
rob's twin brother you guys remember me
i hid this away
while rob was
upstairs this morning doing whatever it
was that he was doing
you guys ever heard of scentbird i'm
here to talk to you all about sunburn
let me tell you something folks smelling
good
is an important thing this one goes here
the green one goes there
the blue one goes there i love senford
check this out scentbird's amazing
ladies gentlemen is for both of y'all
for the ladies and for the gents because
everybody likes to smell good especially
gentlemen
gentlemen ladies like a man that smells
good
smell good
sunburn makes that happen so as you guys
know you go to like the the perfume
counter or anything like that they have
perfume bottles all that kind of stuff
they just they cost a fortune but for 17
a month which is actually seven dollars
for your first month if you use my
coupon code geek culture which you'll
find down in the comments section and
the description of this video and you
can also upgrade to two to three cents a
month if you choose to but you can pay a
monthly subscription fee and that will
get you
different colognes and or perfumes now
my personal favorite is the
mercedes-benz select i love this one the
most because it just smells like money
man that's what this one is it smells
like cash so ladies you'll find this
familiar right it's like perfume you
literally just twist the top and then
you just spray it on
almost smells so great right now uh
gentlemen you literally twist the top
and that's it the best thing about this
or the thing i love the most about this
is that it just fits in your pocket
right so you can literally take it with
you anywhere you want to go right you're
just having like a guy's day and you're
just going out and doing your thing or
whatever going to the bar with the guys
later on you can keep this with you put
it in your pocket ladies if you're going
out and about you keep everything else
in your purse might as well keep one of
these too so you can keep it with you
and then spray a little perfume on if
you feel like you need to you just want
to
smell good i don't
i don't know how the ladies do things
but uh nonetheless
[Laughter]
i do love scentbird it's one of the best
brands that i've ever experienced in my
entire life it's so convenient uh so
make sure you guys check those out again
like one of the ones we got was modern
gentlemen they gave us one with a french
name that i can't pronounce because uh i
failed french
rob failed french too we're just not
good at french you can say stuff like
parvue francais but how are you all
doing how's everybody doing are you all
doing good were you all excited about
d23 rob's still upstairs getting coffee
were you all excited about d23 i was
excited about d23 i absolutely loved it
i thought d23 was amazing rob was super
hyped about it he was really
disappointed that there was no x-men or
fantastic four or or
what else was he complaining about i
don't know there were a bunch of people
who were upset about stuff deadpool he
wanted to see deadpool right i guess you
guys want to see deadpool 2. but i just
want to check in on it you guys know i
like checking in on you from time to
time seeing how you guys are doing so
i'll let rob get back now i know i know
i'll let rob get back to doing his thing
you know whatever you know just for good
measure
how about that so now you gotta open
your laptop again and this is all yours
i will see you all later it was good
talking to you all again tim out
okay
what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to geek culture explained
and as promised we're covering all the
news and stuff really kind of wrapping
up this week on friday with everything
going on regarding the events
of the thunderbolts reveal at d23 and i
gotta tell you guys i am so excited
about the thunderbolts jesus i am so
hyped about this because i feel like
this is marvel studios
finally getting it right so here's the
question who are the thunderbolts right
what's the idea behind the thunderbolts
so while comics explained we'll have a
thunderbolts explained video
around the time the movie comes out
the overall gist of this is that in the
comics the thunderbolts initially
started out in the aftermath of a story
called onslaught which was kind of a
soft reboot by marvel but the general
idea was to essentially
rework the entirety of basically all the
heroes except for like x-men and
spider-man but in their absence when
they were believed to have been dead
baron helmut zemo formed a team called
the thunderbolts where he tricked the
public into thinking he was there to
help when in reality he was there for
just world domination now over the years
the thunderbolts have basically shifted
to where they become more of like a
suicide squad type team not exactly
right you don't really replace the
thunderbolts with folks who die it's one
of those situations where the
thunderbolts are one part villain one
part anti-hero who go on just a series
of missions sometimes they're comedic
sometimes they're super serious but they
kind of operate as a sort of block ops
team kind of a wet work team now of
course the roster has changed over the
years of marvel comics depending on who
it was that was writing the story but
the marvel cinematic universe roster
looks amazing
as soon as i saw that roster i was like
this is going to be a phenomenal movie
the question is is it going to feel like
james gunn's suicide squad is it going
to have that kind of comedy or is it
going to be a darker tone film well we
won't really know until we get closer to
the release and we see the trailer and
more information about the movie starts
coming out but for those of you guys who
didn't see d23 here's the roster
for the thunderbolts team so right off
the bat we've got val who's played by
julia louise dreyfuss you've seen her in
like some post-credit scenes or
different moments over the course of
shows so like she was in falcon in the
winter soldier when she met with john
walker us agent she was in the black
widow film just different things along
those lines but she's going to be the
one that kind of put it together after
that we get ghosts and i'm so excited to
see her return she was an ant-man 2 and
i loved her character i'm so glad to see
she's here because one of the things
that i was really really worried about
is that movie would end and then like
her role in the mc would be the
equivalent of like your voice just
trailing off right she would just kind
of go away and then we just wouldn't see
from her anymore or anything like that
and i'm so excited to see that she's
returning here honestly i still say to
this day just in terms of capabilities
and appearance she's one of the best
villains the marvel cinematic universe
has ever come up with then of course we
have red guardian i have a feeling he's
going to be the comedic relief on the
team right he's going to be just the
funny ones so in place of somebody like
deadpool or something along those lines
i just i love his character in the
marvel cinematic universe he was amazing
in black widow too of course then we get
elena balova and she's going to be like
the super serious one right the one that
just can't take a joke i mean we did see
some comedic elements of her in like
hawkeye for example she's not like super
overly serious 100 of the time but i
don't imagine there's going to be a
whole lot of jokes coming out of her i
think she's going to be the one that's
like this is all about business of
course we do get bucky barnes and i'm
curious about this because i don't know
if bucky barnes is gonna revert back to
being an anti-hero because i'm not gonna
lie
bucky was cool in falcon of the winter
soldier i did love the buddy cop element
between him and sam wilson
but i kind of missed like the villainous
bucky barnes i can't be the only one i
can't be the only one who's kind of like
i sort of missed captain america too the
winter soldier bucky barnes i miss that
guy or like the one from like civil war
i miss that bucky and i'm kind of hoping
we get a return to his character but at
the same time i'm also struggling a
little bit because i do love the
character development that we got for
him over the course of falcon in the
winter soldiers so i'm kind of torn
now that of course leads us into john
walker us agent him i'm more curious
about than anybody else because he's
already like the mentally unstable guy i
imagine a good part of his character
will be like him trying to justify that
like he's as good as captain america i
imagine there might be just like some
rifts between him and bucky where
bucky's like you're no steve rogers and
he's like i know i'm not steve rogers
i'm better you know or something along
those lines so it's going to be
interesting to see how the two of them
square up once they're actually on a
team as opposed to like facing off
against each other like they did in
falcon in the winter soldier and then of
course this leads us into what may very
well be one of the more controversial
and i use the term controversial loosely
but what may very well be one of the
more controversial choices with regards
to character casting in the mcu
task master now i still say that i love
the taskmaster concept i love how it was
implemented in black widow but that not
using tony masters and the task master
school
was a huge missed opportunity by the
marvel cinematic universe they may end
up doing that with taskmaster as it
exists now it is cool to see that like
there's some history there between like
taskmaster projects and the black widow
project and that kind of stuff i don't
really know what direction they're going
to go in i know a lot of people were
hoping that taskmaster as she was
presented in black widow was like the
precursor the prototype for basically
setting up tony masters both in terms of
what the mcu is shooting for as well as
like what was actually happening in the
mcu continuity itself but having said
that i'm not at all upset about it
because one of the things that i love
the most about the character of tony
masters outside of like his own history
was the fact that he just learned to
fight just like other people while he
was watching them fight he would
memorize their moves so to face off
against taskmaster was not to just fight
him it was to fight basically everybody
who's good at hand-to-hand combat in the
marvel cinematic universe and in marvel
comics so i'm curious to see if there's
any additions to the character of
taskmaster and thunderbolts aside from
what we saw in the black widow film has
she for example been watching the
footage on the bus fight between shang
chi and the forces of the mandarin if
that's the case now she's fighting like
shang chi so it's going to be cool to
see her kind of pull out this sort of
rolodex in terms of fighting styles
regarding like all these different
characters it's one of the coolest
things because as these different
characters like iron fists are
reintroduced which fingers crossed will
not be the one that we saw on netflix
that those are fighting styles that can
be brought in for taskmaster to use but
of course this does also ask the
question is the roster going to stay
stagnant and i would say if future
marvel cinematic universe projects are
going to tie into the thunderbolts
that's how they're going to do it by one
reason or another individuals are going
to leave the thunderbolts team now that
may be because ghost is a character that
people just stopped talking about after
a while so the marvel cinematic universe
kills her off because her popularity is
waning there's no reason to have her
there anymore it could be that sebastian
stan's contract runs out and just like
chris evans is captain america he just
kind of rides off into the sunset with a
peaceful life and we just never see or
hear from him again whatever the case
happens to be i think that the roster of
the thunderbolts is actually going to be
a rotating roster i think it's going to
be one of these things where the the
team stays the same name but just
different people come on which is a
genius maneuver because there's a
variety of characters they could use a
really good example of this is that in
the more recent years you actually had a
team of thunderbolts that was assembled
by the red hulk thunderbolt ross and
that team was amazing we actually just
covered the first story arc for that
over comics explain but it's red hulk
deadpool the punisher elektra agent
venom so like flash thompson
spider-man's high school bully when he
basically joins the military and then
gets the venom symbiote at a future
point in time and more recently or
really at the end of that arc the leader
joined the team who of course we're
gonna see in the new captain america
film so if you guys want to see that go
check it out over comics explain it's
really really awesome but like those
characters for the most part don't
really exist per se i mean they do but
they don't we know that william hurt the
late great william hurt he passed away
recently but he played thunderbolt ross
in the marvel cinematic universe now i
doubt they're gonna roll the red hulk in
just because of that i think that some
fans might not really be on par or not
might not really be in favor of somebody
outside of him playing playing red hulk
which i actually agree with that's one
of those rare instances where i'm just
like no leave the character alone like
just leave red hulk out of it even
though it would be cool to see so he
wouldn't necessarily be part of the team
having deadpool on the thunderbolts team
which we know he's coming to the mcu
elektra's coming back in the daredevil
series we know john bernthal's punisher
is coming back to the marvel cinematic
universe there's no indication that
we're gonna see flash thompson's venom
and even then the character of venom is
just a little murky in relation to how
things stand between sony and the mcu
but the point that i'm making here is
there are characters that are coming to
the marvel cinematic universe that we
could potentially see in the foreseeable
future regarding the thunderbolts roster
this team may very well be one of the
most unique and exciting teams that the
marvel cinematic universe has put
together in recent years and that's
really where i think that thunderbolts
will differentiate itself and
potentially even become more interesting
than the avengers films the avengers
films we know that like marvel's just
gonna keep making those they're always
gonna be a mainstay they're always gonna
have a special place in our hearts as
mcu fans because the first avengers film
is just the first major crossover film
so it's always going to have like a
special spot the x-men are going to be
cool fantastic four going to be cool but
i think that what's really going to
differentiate the thunderbolts again
from any other project in the mcu is
that the thunderbolts name will always
be there but the roster will change
relatively consistently i think that's
what's really going to make it unique
they may end up renaming the avengers
right i mean in marvel comics you got a
bunch of different avengers teams you
have the avengers you got the mighty
avengers the new avengers you got the
secret avengers so you have different
names for that team out there but you
only ever have one thunderbolts even
though the roster changes depending on
who's writing the story and what's
happening and so it could be that by the
time we get to king dynasty and secret
wars it's new avengers king dynasty the
mighty avengers secret wars but that's
what i think will really make the
thunderbolts unique among the rest of
the mcu projects but with that being
said guys we're going to bring this
video to an end i want to know your
all's thoughts i want to know your
thoughts on everything regarding the
thunderbolts of the roster and what
potential options we might see and also
make sure you guys check out scentbird
make sure you guys head over there make
sure you guys use the discount code geek
culture down in the comments section so
you can make it seven bucks for your
first month and if you're interested
upgrade to two to three cents per month
after that so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace